if there is a glimmer of hope during
this global pandemic it may be that high
school seniors are now more likely than
ever to get into their dream schools now
that the corona virus pandemic has shut
down nearly all on-campus activities
schools can no longer woo prospective
students there's also a big question
mark surrounding whether international
students will be able to attend next
year unsure about their future many
colleges will be increasing the number
of students they send acceptance and
waitlist emails to in an effort to
ensure that they yield enough students
to fill their incoming class the
colleges and universities typically move
slowly and I have actually been
encouraged as I look out among my
colleagues and see the responses that
institutions have had how quickly
they've really adapted to online
education I received a memo yesterday
from the Provost at the University of
Southern California who said that within
a two-week period they had moved six
thousand courses on la where where
they're going to have some issue I think
is in this whole area of refunds for
room and board many colleges are simply
not going to be able to afford to do
that but families of course we're going
to expect it so there'll be some sort of
tension there and how colleges was all
that and how quickly they resolved that
will will be is something that we've yet
to see but I do predict that those
colleges that are unable to give a
refund will likely give some sort of
credit moving forward the pain won't be
felt evenly however while elite schools
have long wait lists less prestigious
colleges which already struggle to cover
expenses each year face a troubled
future according to Forbes 2019 college
financial grades ranking 675 of the 933
private not-for-profit colleges we
analyzed at grades of C and below
meaning their balance sheets are weak
and their operations fragile
the absence of students from overseas
maybe colleges most pressing problem as
of March 20th the United States
Department of State suspended all
routine visa services
this would include student visas
international students make up nearly
50% of those attending schools such as
New York City's School of Visual Arts
40% of Carnegie Mellon's student body
and some 36% of Columbia University's
enrollment is international another big
issue for colleges is the cost of
refunding room and board for current
students now living at home they're also
dealing with police from parents over
financial aid in 2020 normally federal
financial aid packages are based on 2018
tax returns but with the severe economic
downturn looming colleges will need to
figure out how to incorporate that
reality into financial aid and pricing
many international schools may not be
able to either get a visa in time to be
here in the fall or if they are they may
be concerned about coming to the United
States at this time if kovat is not
contained by that time so there there
will be some options I think that
colleges will pursue in terms of online
education for students abroad to get
started in the curriculum some colleges
may do this on their own
some colleges may contract with vendors
who are providing a service for example
a CT and Shore light and Hudsonville
scholars I have contracted to work with
particular students abroad to get them
started on their college experience and
then transfer those credits back to
other institutions last December a
Department of Justice settlement made it
fair game for colleges to poach other
schools and rolled students including
those that were accepted early decision
so what is turning out to be a nightmare
scenario for college administrators may
work to the advantage of anxious high
school seniors and their family
buyer beware however not all colleges
are likely to survive fallout from the
corona virus pandemic
you